From within in our RStudio Cloud workspace,
there are four possible roles
that an individual can occupy.
As the creator of the workspace
we are given the default status
of administrator, and we cannot change
that status. Administrators
have full privileges within workspace.
Administrators can manage the workspace
and all of the projects,
including their own,
and also view all of the projects
within a workspace,
including private projects.
Moderators have all of the same privileges
as an administrator,
except that moderators cannot add
or remove learners from the workspace.
This means that moderators can manage
all of the projects,
as well as view all of the projects
within a workspace.
Contributors can create
and manage their own projects,
and they can also view any projects
that have been shared with them.
As an administrator or moderator,
we can also control
whether or not contributors can see the
names of other members in the workspace,
make their projects visible to all
members, and change project resources.
Users have the most
restrictive permissions
and can only view projects
that have been shared with the workspace
or with them as an individual.
As an administrator or moderator
we can also control
whether or not a viewer can see the names
of other members in the workspace.